Charlotte, I would like to endorse you to be the next president of the United States.
Oh my god.
You've been a great secretary.
Of State.
Which state again?
All of them.
Is that the Secretary of State looking at us?
I kind of know her.
It's like kind of knowing a mermaid.
Do you tell people that?
She probably doesn't remember who I am.
Secretary Field would like to speak with you.
With me?
I can't shake this feeling that we know each other.
We do!
We do?
Picture me, I guess, maybe like 20 years younger, but like this.
Flarsky?
Yeah.
What are you doing these days?
I'm a journalist.
You're a great writer, but, sometimes you're a little too much.
I don't think I am too much! I actually think I'm the perfect, right, portion.
It's really nice to see you again.
Woah!
*screaming*
Cracker down!
I'm okay!
Okay, did he just call me a cracker?
What is the relationship exactly?
*chuckles*
It's to babysit for him.
You babysat for him?
Wow. Time has not been kind.
I need some writers to punch up my speeches.
Fred's writing is really good and he knows me.
Oh, I feel so scared.
In order to write better for you, I should kind of get to know you better... if you have a minute.
I actually have seven.
Seven minutes in heaven.
*chuckles*
What is your favourite book as a kid?
The Velveteen Rabbit.
Favourite song?
'Must have been loved' by Roxette.
Most embarrassing moment?
I don't know embarrass that easily.
I don't either, really.
What's your favourite sexual position?
Normal, front-facing, normal.
What kind of question is that?
That's all it took, look at you!
*stuttering* What's your favourite sexual position?
Don't be gross, alright?
Do a date.
I mean, who wants to follow me around the world and hope I have five minutes to be affectionate?
Yeah.
We did almost just die.
We actually did almost die.
We need to move you.
Thank you, Agent M.
It's 'Pretty Woman', but she's Richard Gere and you're Julia Roberts.
Honestly, this has been the best few weeks of my entire life.
We asked a thousand constituents how they would feel if Kate Middleton-
I see where you're going with this.
-were to start dating Danny DeVito.
Pretty negative reaction.
The last time you got high was on a *inaudible* concert?
We have a situation.
Huh?
I'm in so much trouble.
What's happened? Are they out of water?
*laughing*
Wow, he's so bendy, huh?
Ooh!
Ouch!